hi welcome to poly bridge this is a game
where I build the bridge and everyone
else can also submit a bridge that they
have all right so Road easy done perfect
it is perfect done damn I'm a genius
damn I'm a genius wait how do I get to
you guys's suggestions here try again
I have people's suggestions here what is
this
who made that this is not helpful
it's not this is you didn't put roads
guys guys this problem what is that what
is this supposed to be it's it's a penis
this has been Venus Venus truly
something terrible I can't just guys I
hate to say these are these are
god-awful these are the worst designs
I've ever this isn't where do you think
this road is going to go alright let's
try to improve this one let's go let's
at least connect it here
okay so girthy holds here the Zout
design is done here we go perfect done
let's see let's see her all right well
what is hi hi-yah hi-yah are you doing
ah I thought that was gonna work there
alright Lorelei this
I don't think you guys understand the
basic principles oh oh hey yeah well
alright yes you spelled mark I hate you
I don't know if this is hey actually
stunningly that worked shockingly how
does someone do it with 300 and what I
did somebody with 353 that doesn't make
any sense no no no no no you know
actually that's pretty good I gotta
admit that's pretty good that's bad
penis you guys are truly something
terrible there there thank you BAM oh
okay cool
thank you good we got that one nailed it
next level unmute suggestions you know I
think I'm okay
build a bridge on a slope all right I'll
build a bridge on a slope BAM I've built
the bridge on a slope
all right build the bridge on a slope
build the bridge on a slope Wow I'm a
genius how do you do it with 1307 how do
you do it oh there's breaks in it huh
interesting interesting interesting all
right what do you guys guys oh my god
what is this
no f you fail you what is it ah here we
go now we got it
[Laughter]
I need some quality control on this I
need some quality control
how do you all suggestions must be a
prude I don't even know what that do I
feel like my mods would just be the
first one to put penises in here I mean
sure no no this is another penis
moderators doing failed me this is a
penis I think this is what you call
abusive moderation privileges what the
hell no no is that P the P that's B
that's B that's P you right thank you
Thanks oh crap
how about just we get through this one I
think that um how about we get ramp ramp
as' ramp that's gonna break
[Music]
maybe we could help improve this design
clearly it's got the ambition for it
this is what I call reinforcement
perfect
now it'll make it perfect we did it we
got it we got it guys we got it perfect
build a bridge of Steel steel is much
stronger than wood but it is also very
expensive
according to WHO reinforced Road how
much does a reinforced road cost a lot
twice as much all right you've got it
easy
whoa big uns guys let me get it first
let me get the correct solution first
and then all of you guys can la-dee-da
way elsewhere perfect this is gonna work
love it like a dream like a dream like a
dream Oh what do you got oh well that's
nice I'm sure it'll work that's lovely
these are lovely designs guys these
designs are truly something spectacular
these are really good this is good a
plus a plus on this one mm-hmm
be - I didn't quite work out the way I
really uh really didn't do it this is
great good stuff
a plus I don't think so ooh
[Laughter]
loop-de-loop maybe oh no your boy here
we go
I don't know if heavy construction
equipment was meant to loop deep oh it's
a mark upside-down can't believe this
this feels like a waste of money
that's not connected there I like your
ambition but the loop-d-loop doesn't
seem to want to go anywhere
all right cool good job I'd say
ambitious jump oh it's not even a jump
ie it's an Express route down to Neptune
himself a thing of beauty right there Oh
interesting
ask good stuff that's pretty
high-quality I gotta admit that's not
bad all right let's get out of here okay
14 meter overpass
don't let boats hit your bridge trying
to try to build over it well that's easy
enough you need to get a nice gentle
sloping slope
slow ping uh-huh
this is what they call genius this big
brain hours here perfect working
perfectly
easy what it was the view typically get
the different view on that and what what
am I seeing oh oh that's delightful
that's really lovely that worked out
really good now I can't wait to see you
guys's hmm
I don't I don't all right that didn't
work I there's no roads
do you do you guys do know how to play
right just all right you're trying to
get the truck on the boat I see I
appreciate it I you came so close you
came so close yours you were so close
[Music]
nope I don't know why I get excited
every single time I see something like
that now and don't worry this now a -
nope no nope Oh ramp all right let's try
it
hey sis replace those are steel and then
baby you guys still going easy really
there's nothing
Hey
end it a cool flip you're welcome I
helped that now filmy checkpoints cars
must collect their checkpoints before
collecting their flag oh I see I see so
you gotta go up to here and then you
gotta go down to there how are you guys
done are you're not don't try to fool me
you're not done I know you're not then
supports perfectly that top ones
definitely in there 100% you guys are
about to witness the glory of what could
have been if I had decided to pursue
engineering this is what the world is
missing out on and I feel that they weep
every night because they know they can
never experience my full magnificence
and I know this and I to cry at night
knowing that the world is deprived of my
genius I know this
I'm sorry
ah okay this is clearly a problem that's
not my own fault clearly an issue with
why is this not moving there we go
clearly an easy solution but also very
much not my fault I didn't know that
this game would be limited in such a way
they wouldn't be able to properly
replicate the correct conditions for
life I'm a genius you could say it right
now you could write it down how much of
a genius I am all right what do you got
what maybe why do I say maybe why do I
bother saying maybe why do I even try to
defend your horrifying designs maybe God
every time okay
maybe Hey Oh
no no no all right the mythical double
loop-de-loop purpose i don't think you
understand the problem
[Laughter]
I like it all right I like it that's
good that's good that's very good use
hydraulics to create a drawbridge some
levels have hydraulics would you like it
tutorial on hydraulics sure hydraulics
allow your bridges to change shape we
have to modify this bridge to allow the
boat to pass click the continue to
Pistons on the guidelines above you got
it both hydraulics may expand a curtain
track to 50% of their original length
drag the arrow of the hydraulic to the
right side for 50% expansion
double-click the indicator joined to
Chris split joint if we simulated the
bridge would now tear itself apart
remove the two indicated all right you
got it now we can simulate the
hydraulics move it's important to know
where your rotation points are oh this
adds a new element oh this is different
oh ok I got it let me let me put my
genius to it and then you all can have
your moment of non genius and I will
laugh at thee
okay so spliff joint this is gonna be
good ok so what's gonna happen is this
pistons gonna push this part way way up
it's gonna push it so that's not gonna
work it's gonna push it so up you're
gonna see how up this is about to get
it's about to get real up it's about to
get so up in here it's gonna go up
ok you see what I'm you see do you see
that'll work and then this one we're
gonna have it pull we're gonna pull it
from up top P stands for pull so I know
it needs to pull this way it's gonna
pull no it's gonna pull it so I need
this to pull it
there he's gonna pull it pull see how
this does
it worked
cuz it worked I gotta pull it P stands
for pull so if I pull it then then it
will pull then I'll pull it and then it
pulls and then it'll pull it up and then
it will be pulled then it's gonna pull
it not hang on everybody sure shush
shush it's gonna pull it because I can
pull if I'm pulling it then I need it to
pull and when I pull it it's gotta pull
up and when I pull it up then it gets
pulled of course all of these need to
pull up no you don't you don't pull down
there's no such thing it's like
centripetal centrifugal force it doesn't
exist
[Laughter]
I did it everybody guys I did it you
proud there we go okay okay good this
actually we're I'm shocked that this
worked out let's just pull one of them
now this is gonna work perfect I'm sorry
I meant to put it this way and yeah yeah
you got to pull this you're gonna pull
it you're pulling it you're gonna pull
it you're gonna pull the thing contract
you expand it you can contract it you
contract it oh wait no hang on that my
god
I'm a genius I did it on top 98% I did
it what
[Laughter]
very it's really good it's really good
it's really good move to me Oh
ah oh no no what yeah good that really
worked good stuff oh that's beautiful
that's really good that works perfectly
that's fantastic that was really good
that was really good really good oh my
god pull pull pull pull
why am I so far Oh
that really worked that's really nice
that's a good one
that's a good one all right seven
checkpoints reverse the direction of the
car so it needs to go there and back is
what you're saying
okay sure easy peasy
big brain mode what can I say have a
nice day
all right what you got I just I question
the you just spam what yeah of course it
didn't work course of course of course I
should have suspected a long time ago
what no your ambition is great here I
don't think oh my god your ambition was
pretty good however thank you to
the prompt but that was good sounds very
good that was very good oh my god oh my
god
[Applause]
all right no no aah there's good stuff
man's good stuff this probably is good
that looks good that's good stuff there
we go a plus a plus a plus on that one
that's good great job guys you get
I question this I just want to say I
question this I question this greatly
and yet here I go I don't want to drive
across the bridge that's held up by too
hot but here we go how do you wait yeah
let me see I want to see if you can
delete half of these what will happen
well I guess then Tom Tilton mm Tom
tough mmm no suspected I don't see why
not
that's good stuff man ah you wanna go
for a dip so can you take a little bit
of water can't even oh poor baby can't
even take just a little bit of water nor
what if it's not what if it's only just
the splishy-splashy astir mount of water
what if it's like baby water you're
gonna take out the bullet oh this will
work no it won't but what but what if
about what is
[Music]
thank you this is great there's good
stuff what this is good stuff guys this
good thanks thank you thank you there
you go very lovely you guys so I'm proud
of you what budget
oh it's low budget okay easy tiny itty
bitty bridge hey wait no how do I not
have enough money what it's just that
all right this might be a little tricky
Brian and then all you would need is
that no it's perfect
we're fine I did it top 29% baby I did
it I did it I did it now how did you get
that's my that's my design that way we
did the same thing it's pretty hey hey
it's all variations of the same oh it's
all the same we're all heterogeneous ah
I've fear we are not all heterogeneous
Oh No that New Mexico very good yeah
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
Finch at Finch at Oh Oh F in check
everything you guys have ever been
allowed to do I regret I regret all of
you ever thinking that you could how
dare you I don't think this thing got
the speed loop do you leave a space for
a loop-de-loop No lazy's I'm gonna build
a loop-d-loop I'm gonna show you guys
I'm gonna show you what will show you
what the hell is up all right here we go
baby
[Laughter]
unsafe yeah you got that right Oh
this is gonna work all right
that's a nice under bridge that's good
I'm leaving goodbye sometimes jumping to
campus the best all right guys you heard
him sometimes jump into gap bessel all
right guys
spring oh no guys it's time it's our
time guys it's our time it's we've been
waiting for this for so long
okay so what I want is to really like
springboard this son of a out of
here he ain't gonna know nothing about
nothing about where the hell he went
really it's okay start stretched and
it's gonna bring him okay
oh it goes right away okay well that's
interesting
all right forget about this forget about
this this was a terrible idea it's
terrible terrible idea this was horrible
the idea was that you were gonna jump it
jump okay we're gonna we're gonna jump
it we're gonna jump it okay it's gonna
get jumped okay let's see how it jumps I
just want to see where it jumps to whoa
okay perfect that's actually excellent
that is actually excellent okay so what
we need is gonna be called the hug okay
right it's gonna be called the hug man
the hug didn't quite get him don't know
why they try again I think so no the hug
the hug is just a little flawed at the
moment it'll it'll pick it up though
guys don't
the hug the hug is fine the hugs good
hugs good baby hugs good I think isn't
this the idea you're supposed to sprung
it
I feel like this I gotta improve the hug
the hug needs improvement is what the
hug needs can I assign multiple doodads
to the same road the hug is imbrue Oh
hug one hug with a little funny hit
there I'm not sure what the hug did huh
okay so clearly the problem is that
there's not enough hugging strength here
so I have to reinforce the hug with more
arms I've got to get the hug Arminius
gooder I'm gonna do a steel-reinforced
hug it's like a hug bear trap if a bear
trap was meant for love the hug is gonna
be just a nightmare of wires and mesh
man oh man is it gonna feel good when
you get hugged by this thing here we go
hug baby good hello put that down to
regulars bed it's get a good look at
where that dog embraces it here comes
doing this is not how hugs work is it
how hugs work it's about that one think
you forgot roads
you forgot the road part of the hug
licks you to it licks Ian no licks it
how meant Mitch drug once pretty for all
right good job that's that's good stuff
no no no no no you guys weren't even
listening when I talked about the hog
you guys weren't even listening alright
they've got a little flappy dangle but
maybe the love is there I'm surprised
here we go now this is a hug oh there's
no roads damn alright good job good job
okay stop and go some checkpoints stop
the car is that a good thing are you
supposed to stop the car I'm guessing a
stopping the car was part of the entire
experiment to begin with cuz it's gonna
push that up and this is gonna attention
to Diana stat this and then we just need
something to push this up well do I need
to do anything else besides the stopping
is the stopping actually pertinent to my
everyday life you expand you expand good
okay alright okay alright let's see it
lets see it stop stop
dear God stop no no no what happened
what happened
why why do that break Oh coz there's
nothing supporting this when you
contract yeah you'll contract and then
you will contract meaning you'll pull
yes
easy easy easy easy easy easy easy
peace for Paul Pierce for Paul easy easy
this is easy give me something hard give
me something hard what do you guys got
looks good looks good looks good I know
that'll work that'll work that'll
definitely that'll work yeah
[Laughter]
Oh No what the hell happened oh it's a
misery why no no let's let's okay it's
like the teachers gotta correct the
students work a little bit here I think
there's really something here I think
there's something here I think I think
this design has potential I think I
think that this is this is like a dream
come true for me I loved seeing people's
creativity come through this good good
stuff puppets who didn't complete the
tutorial
you just didn't complete the tutorial
there good good you didn't do it oh good
you love to see it it'll never stop if
it never touches it all right
I spy a problem and here's the proboscis
where the bridge becomes erect so that's
you know I'll take it
I'll take that one that's a good one
that's a good Oh perhaps we can use that
rock to our advantage you know perhaps
not all right so what do we got to do we
actually got to do the let
things lie what things just rest honey
is that what I got to do is that what
you're telling me I need to do is this
what my imaginary engineering degree has
become is it well I didn't mark go whose
lime oh is this perfect diamond John yes
what does it like to compare your
intelligence to mine and find it so
woeful e inadequate what is that like
that must be 57 how there's no way that
is not possible that's not you didn't
how did you do it with 57 dollars no no
incorrect no credit I I'm gonna put you
in detention
I'm gonna put you in detention you
deserve to go in detention
this is awful this is awful you didn't
even try well no the problem is you did
try and this clearly takes a lot of
effort but you just didn't try what how
are you on this level of the game and
you don't understand how to do it you
didn't touch the rock you son of a
you built everywhere but the rock
rock was all we had
okay what does this do what does this
accomplish isn't this just my design but
you add into this over this is what I
built this is exactly what I built why
did you add this sanity sanity here as
sanity kaha I tell you don't get that
you didn't read do you don't have roads
no uses try it you say came so close
it hurts my brain it hurts my brain you
proved all roads oh it's so stable
except there aren't any right all right
here we go this is did you get to this
rock is rock I found this a please work
or piss work oh no loop-de-loops do not
work
what's this - 702 God I preached that
but no drawbridge no treat no cheating
now you made just wish size splitjoin
material kiss but you're just plain will
regard with one area normally one
splitjoin activates one stay connected
to the other ones and to stay connect to
the other twos okay let me handle it let
me handle it let's first the road the
road is simple the road cannot change
the split happens exactly where it must
be and then this happens exactly as it
would does and that's the law this is
what shall be okay perfect it's gonna
contract that's what I love to see this
is what I love to see this is why I am
Who I am this is why me am what me do I
am smart the biggest smart brain hang on
okay just check this just wanted to
check just to check something real quick
it's fine it's fine it's fine you know
why because this is why this is why this
is why look at that all right we didn't
need that anyway that's why this is not
necessary yes yes yes it's all coming
together now yes yes yeah yes yes maybe
I could hold it there
my genius knows no limit no limit has
ever been known by my genius my genius
is inescapable have you guys ever seen
my genius have I showed you my genius
have you ever gandered at my genius
my genius knows no bounds you all marvel
at the mighty sheer power of my genius
my genius is unstoppable my John yes I'm
over-budget god damn it fine my genius
will no no limits
why would I don't need one that big it
doesn't need to be that big is the thing
size doesn't matter the truth that was
in front of my eyes all along size isn't
everything it doesn't need to be that
big guys it doesn't need to be that big
it doesn't even need to be this tall it
just doesn't need to be that big you can
do a lot with a little bit you don't
need it you don't need it all you don't
need all of it you just need a little of
it it's like there's such a thing as too
much eyes a minute I see the truth for
what it is you don't need it you don't
need it it's the thing that's what you
know the the the commercials all tell
you you need it you need the biggest
thing you need you need the hugest one
but you don't
the magic is you don't you don't need it
[Music]
we are no forgot to put
all right let's see what you guys got
this is awful what have you done
whatever you're done no you can't cheat
that's the thing you can't do the
cheating five I don't I don't have five
orphans anymore you don't need it no
that's what I was saying you don't you
don't need it you don't need this is
over budget and you don't need it you
don't need the thing there we go
that's the way that's the way that's the
way that's the way this will work
perfectly that's the way that's how you
do it
that's the way top ninety-eight percent
that's terrible that was awful what did
that even do for anybody
what is this nightmare what is the
self-destructing nightmare
what is this mud to me what is this
I don't even I oh oh oh what is it
pulling on what are you bowling you're
awful you should feel better it doesn't
work oh oh Jesus Christ I can't
I don't think all right
[Laughter]
[Music]
I don't know how you keep finding new
ways to fail oh that's very nice
[Music]
okay
I got my hopes up for why it's very good
day hey could this work what is
happening here could this actually work
no there's no way there's no way there's
no way that this is gonna work this
won't work
there's no way wow that actually worked
oh I think I'm good
I think I'm this was an experiment and
it clearly you guys aren't ready to go
out into the world but hey kudos there
are an infinite possibility of correct
solutions and there are an infinite
possibility of incorrect solutions and
you have found all of them
you found all of the incorrect solutions
you've found every one of them thank you
for showing me that there there is no
hope left
well done I'm gonna go cry I will cry
I'm going to cry for those watching this
on youtube I played this live on Twitch
don't go there
it's a
people there are strange people all
right okay bye-bye
[Music]
you